savez vous à quoi sert un coronographe
pas observé un virus mais un objet
beaucoup plus volumineux dont le
diamètre fait presque cent dix fois
celui de la terre et qui est située à
150 millions de kilomètres de nous un
coronographe permet d'observer la
couronne du soleil et ses magnifiques
jets de matière on appelle cela une
protubérance il a été mis au point par
un astronome français bernard lions en
1931 au pic du midi de bigorre dans les
pyrénées il est constitué d'un cash qui
se fixe sur un télescope et qui masque
la totalité du disque solaire c'est le
seul moyen d'observer la couronne du
soleil
sans lui le rayonnement est trop
important pour voir ce qui s'y passe et
de toute façon c'est extrêmement
dangereux on ne regarde jamais le soleil
a tenu ni même avec des lunettes de
soleil
on peut facilement perdre la vue avant
les astronomes devait attendre une
éclipse totale du soleil pour observer
sa couronne et encore pendant quelques
minutes et franchement ça n'arrive pas
tous les quatre matins avec le
coronographe on peut observer la
couronne du soleil tous les jours dès
que le ciel est dégagé et profiter de
ces magnifiques protubérance de
véritables capsules de confirmer
certaines s'étire sur plusieurs
centaines de milliers de kilomètres
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celle des jours précédents cliquant sur
le côté gauche jean publie une nouvelle
chaque jour et pour être sûr de ne
louper aucune et bien abonnez vous et
activer la petite cloche à demain et
n'oubliez surtout pas nous sommes
toujours confiné mais en restant rien